[Musik]
aus berlin mit lutz van der horst und
den sonstigen parteien zur
bundestagswahl post aber fair
hallo herzlich willkommen zu horst aber
fair
das ist meine gäste die magdeburger
garten partei kämpfe übernachtung im
schrebergarten
die frauen wollen mehr frauen in
machtpositionen die menschliche welt
möchte eine menschliche welt wo die
gerade partei hält das schild schief was
mach ich jetzt können sie wieder
hinlegen machen sie gerade die raute ich
merke ich mache gerade meine finger zu
sehen
das ist nicht die merkel konnte wie das
ist ein zeichen das ist ein zeichen der
frauenbewegung
das wollten sie natürlich auch nicht
machen das ist ein zeichen der frauen
bewegen ja das heißt was bedeutet dieses
solle die waage
die volumina evelina soll es bedeuten
das klingt doch kurz erschrocken wie das
ist aber warum wohl wiener und nicht
wahr es gibt wohl wahr und vagina und
eigentlich bezeichnet beides das
weibliche geschlecht kann man auch
scheide sagen sie ja scheide ist ja
eigentlich nur die vagina durch die
berliner nicht die vulva heißt penis
weiterhin penis ich glaube schon
nächstes thema türkei konflikt schüler
wenn sie die möglichkeit hätten sich
müssen in die türkei und mit erdogan
reden würden sie tun
ich würde mal gut wir spielen die
situation durch ich bin erdogan am tag
das hat nichts mit guten tag zu tun okay
ich bin hetero an wir sollten das jetzt
sehr schwer den ernstfall durch und wer
sie hatten zwei personen sich treffen
wir spielen das jetzt durch ok was ich
bin jetzt erdogan am montag auch schon
und was ist ihr problem
das sollen sie für ein problem ich habe
kein problem du als gleichen probleme
ich habe kein problem sie sind doch zu
mir gekommen
ja ich bin zu ihnen vorschläge für zumal
ja die finde ich aber nicht gut auf
wiedersehen gut und damit wäre das
gespräch
das ist die große frage ob es dann
wirklich zu ende ist jetzt haben wir von
der magdeburger garten partei den sieht
die garten partei als den größten gegner
in deutschland den linksextremismus den
rechtsextremismus oder den borkenkäfer
ich glaub mal der borkenkäfer ist sehr
gefährlich und der es eigentlich
schleppt wurden aus china
der ist gar nicht bei uns groß geworden
den gibt es den gab es früher gar nicht
in deutschland also überfremdung über
der afg klich da hätten wir einfach die
politiker früher besser drauf aufpassen
müssen
er ist einer der gefährlichsten gegner
in der forstwirtschaft der doch was
sollte man nicht unterschätzen
wie stehen sie denn dann zu so zu so was
ich in borken zu ungeziefer darf man das
vernichten
das prinzip ist ja leben lebt von leben
und wenn ein höher entwickeltes leben
bedroht wird von einem niedrigen
entwickelten leben dann ist es natürlich
sinnvoll so zu handeln dass das meer
entwickelt
überlebt da würde die afg aber auch
wieder zustimmen ich meine zu einer
firma auf der straße fahren und sie
haben vor uns auf der straße jetzt links
ein kind dann da 1 1 eine ganz und
rechts ein käfer und daneben pflanzen
und daneben den abgrund wo würde ich
dann fahre ich könnte natürlich die
pflanzen und den käfer retten werden wir
das auto in dem ich in den graben in den
abgrund fahren das würde keinen sinn
machen also ich würde dann dorthin
fahren wenn ich jetzt nicht bremsen
könnte wo ich halt über die pflanzen
fahren würde
wie sieht das die garten partei pflanzen
als minderwertig also wir grenzen würden
sie zum beispiel er was war das noch
kind also ein kind an der pflanze wo
würden sie also dass gegen fahren wenn
sie müssen das sagt doch eindeutig auch
unser oder stvo ist dass wir da werden
die junge wäre
wir können nichts kosten würde berichtet
ausführen
wir kommen zum nächsten thema nordkorea
konflikt jetzt sollten wir eigentlich
belegt bild einblenden von der
startenden rakete waren die bildrechte
zu teuer dürfte ich sie bitten nur damit
die zuschauer wissen worum es geht das
wir kurz eine rakete machen um in
stimmung zu kommen
ok kommando 1,1 2,3
[Musik]
die diese affäre vor müller von die frau
und auch wenn sie sich als frau
natürlich nichts mit autos auskennen
aber da habe ich keine ahnung
er hat deswegen fragen sie mich aber das
sagt glaube ich nichts damit zu tun dass
ich eine frau bin also wie er mir
vertraut aber es fällt auf dass wir auch
leider am ende der sendung sind das
heißt ich würde sie jetzt noch mal
bitten in einem satz zu sagen warum man
sie wählen sollten wir müssen das leider
gleichzeitig machen und das mal in kunst
und rennen also jetzt bitte alle
zusammen bei 31 23 die theorie zu
solchen schritten anfangen
nein danke das war's mit horst aber fair
danke dass sie meine gäste waren jetzt
mal klatschen und
die schweiz
[Musik]
[Applaus]